I think that's a great question you know
I do think you know as I said I think
property rights and connection to a
large market creates good incentive to
produce but that's primarily to produce
you know what we call private goods so
to make food or cell phones or
televisions or you know film all of
which can be consumed by individuals but
capitalism is not a good system for
taking care of public goods and I think
the in this current era we've got more
and more countries that are buying into
the notion of property rights and free
trade so the global economy is growing
faster than it has for a long time and
that's good for raising living standards
and reducing poverty but it also creates
some new problems because there are
global issues that cannot easily be
dealt with just by the capitalist system
itself and I think the most important is
the global environment and I'm
particularly concerned about the issue
of global warming so we're in a pretty
nice situation now where a lot of
developing countries are growing well
creating jobs and lifting people out of
poverty which is great but now we have
this challenge of collective action you
know how do we preserve the global
Commons and how do we take care of the
you know the earth basically so that
this development can be sustainable and
there i think you know they're the
solution and you know in simple terms
the solution there is not property
rights the solution there is collective
action and we are in a situation where
you've got all these different countries
in the world we don't really have a
system of global government we've got a
United Nations you know which is you
know doing its best to deal with
security issues but it's not really
global government we don't really have
any kind of global framework for
managing the global environment you know
we've got the Kyoto Protocol to begin to
deal with greenhouse gas emissions but
that's very partial it only involves
commitments from a small number of
countries you've got big players like
the u.s. that have not signed up in all
the developing countries were exempt so
I think
getting the collective action to the
general issue is the collective action
to produce public goods and I think the
best example to make this concrete is
the whole issue of preserving the global
environment including greenhouse gases
and global warming I think the other
obvious one is in the health field you
know that the general issue here there
are things that are really public goods
in the sense that if you're new
communicable disease develops of avian
influenza develops as a human disease
that can spread right then that's a
that's a global public concern you know
you can have a global health epidemic of
different types so that's another good
example where you really need countries
to cooperate to set up you know rules
about what happens when diseases develop
how do you investigate these you know
how do you quarantine people and I you
know I think all due respect to the
World Health Organization I don't think
we have a strong global regime for
managing these these global public
health issues so i think the the
environment environmental issues are the
most obvious lack in the current world
and then I think dealing with global
health issues is the second area of
obvious concern
you